[Music]
you've been in the business how long
when Ted you get started as a youngster
yes I 95 I started in the business Wow
and my first gig was Dawson's Creek yeah
you were on Dawson's Creek oh yeah I was
well I was going to school in Virginia
and I remember we had to it was a really
big deal to get an audition for Dawson's
Creek because it was shot and Wilmington
North Carolina and we had to drive like
five hours to get to the audition in
five hours back and then I got the gig I
was playing a doctor and all this kind
of stuff and I remember I was really
nervous and I wanted my steam was with
james van der beek and i wanted to be
really cool and I thought maybe we'll be
friends you know yeah it could happen it
can happen yeah and he doesn't remember
this but I I remember it was kind of
chilly but he had like a lot of coats on
and like several like layers there's no
coats and I remember my the second thing
I said to him after like hi I said dude
you look hot and he kind of looked at me
and I was I was coming on my mouth I was
like stop and I couldn't stop and then
he was called off to set and I'm not
kidding I literally said no I meant take
it off
and for the whole day he just thought I
was coming on alright so then you live
for a bunch of years in New York yeah
yeah yeah and you got smaller roles here
and there yeah yeah I did a little bit
on Sopranos what did you plan the
Sopranos I remember you know well this
is what this is what happened I you know
it's a very it's a I'm a hugely popular
show at the time and it still is and
very kind of a lot of thugs and
hyper-masculine
and I remember this one of the guys came
out to me he's like hey you know what
are you playing what are you playing and
I said well I'm playing the male nurse
yeah so you were the male nurse and he
just goes you were the male nurse yes
Sopranos yes I was
yeah but you sold it I did sell it